Розрив дипломатичних відносин передбачає
відкликання послів і закриття амбасад,
проте не означає повного припинення контактів між країнами
чи розірвання двохсторонніх угод.
Комунікація з Росією відбуватиметься не напряму,
а через країну-посередника.
З-поміж держав, які могли би представляти інтереси України,
у ЗМІ, приміром, раніше називали Білорусь та Швейцарію.
Остання, до речі, стала посередницею між Грузією та Росією,
коли ті розірвали відносини
після війни 2008 року.
Одна із загроз розриву дипломатичних відносин
полягає в тому, що підтримка українців,
які живуть і працюють в Росії, може стати обмеженою.
За даними російської міграційної служби,
в РФ перебуває 2 мільйони українських громадян.
Утім, попри відсутність посольств,
українські консульські установи мають право
продовжити працювати в Росії та надавати послуги.
Розрив дипломатичних відносин не означає автоматичного
впровадження обмежень на пересування громадян між країнами.
Теоретично українці все одно зможуть
їздити до Росії і навпаки.
Втім, складнощі таки можуть виникнути, якщо буде
запроваджено візовий режим, що часто трапляється
після розриву дипломатичних відносин.
Отже, в теорії наслідки розриву дипломатичних відносин
не повинні суттєво зашкодити українцям, які живуть
в Росії, а торкнуться переважно
способу комунікації двох держав. На практиці усе
може бути значно складніше.
Адже якою буде реакція Москви на такий можливий крок Києва,
нині спрогнозувати складно.